caitlyn jenner and lady gaga are going
viral for a hilarious yet very awkward
exchange at elton john's oscar viewing
party so thankfully a video posted to
twitter captured the moment with other
youtube users online helping supply the
subtitles
[Music]
ah i appreciate the subtitles because i
don't know if i would have heard all
that did you feel that did you feel like
the
i mean
i okay i uh
the i switched barista's thing now that
can either be like a sort of low-key
shade whatever it was or lady gaga could
actually be the type of person who no
longer goes there because she did in
fact switch burritos right you seriously
okay so that video quickly went viral
with everyone reacting to gaga saying
she's switched baristas it's not
everyone's new favorite line one twitter
user suggested i've switched baristas is
literally the most polite way of saying
if i ever see you again
it'll be too soon or guys she looked
like she was on a red carpet she looked
like she was in the middle of an
interview no i don't i don't know if
this is the if this is the shade you
think it is i know i don't i didn't
think it was around i really don't i
think gaga is in fact a person who
changed coffee shops because she
switched baristas i like i don't i don't
think that i switched barrisses is the
is the shade that you think it is are
you that dedicated to your starbucks
barista yeah i don't know is that a
thing i didn't know that was a thing i
don't know now dude like gaga like i
understand that that would be an
interesting
interaction between two people because
you have lady gaga who has done so much
for the lgbtq community born this way
sure all of this stuff but then you have
caitlyn jenner who is trans they should
be besties but their politics don't
align this is true and how do you
justify and manage that conversation
where you don't want to look rude
because half of you
you know really fights for somebody like
caitlyn jenner but the other half of you
realize that a lot of what caitlyn
jenner fights for goes against your own
moral code and compass and so that in
itself is a very odd conversation and
dynamic to be around but to me it seemed
like you know caitlyn jenner wanted to
just have a moment and let's not be
political i'm a huge fan haven't seen
you in a while obviously at some point
they did get along these were cordial um
with each other so uh i don't know but
maybe i'm wrong maybe i switch baristas
is the disc that everybody says it is
it's so funny cap status is saying lady
gaga wanted to walk away fast but just
stayed to be polite
eye rock saying lady gaga is vain um
yeah i don't know maybe this is just
like the nice canadian girl in me but i
was like no way lady gaga was throwing
shade and i'm like she just seemed like
she was busy yeah is it shady or is it
pretentious because it's only going to
be one of those two things right is it
shady as in i switch baristas meaning i
never want to see you again or is it uh
is it pretentious meaning i switch
baristas as in i actually did switch
baristas and that's the way that's the
reason why i don't go there that's why
everyone's freaking out about this i
don't know i and i don't and i don't
know but i think that that is the sort
of beauty of a clip like this is that uh
is that we may never know and if anybody
thinks that at any point lady gaga is
actually going to sit and down in an
interview and answer the question
whether she actually did switch baristas
ladies is never gonna you're never gonna
get close enough to lady gaga to even
ask that question so it's going to be a
mystery which i am here for i think she
switched baristas you do i do yeah